JUDY SINGER: Good afternoon
everyone, I'm Judy Singer,
I'm the Vice Provost for Faculty
Development and Diversity,
and I want to thank you all
for joining us this afternoon
for this panel on academics
writing books for audiences
that are beyond academia.
We have been running, from the
Senior Vice Provost's Office,
a number of book events
over the last few years,
all designed to
bring Harvard faculty
together to talk about
the publication process,
to try to facilitate
your publishing,
getting contacts with
editors, and getting
an inside
behind-the-scenes look.
This particular event
has proved so popular
we actually had to turn people
away, and so we're videoing it,
so it will be up on the web to
be available to other people.
The purpose of this
particular event
is to stretch
ourselves a little bit,
and to think not just about
the audiences we typically
write for in terms of our
professional colleagues,
but also the wider world.
Part of being a
Harvard faculty member
is having an impact
on your field.
But part of being a
Harvard faculty member
is to have an impact
beyond your field.
The context for this work
though is a little bit tricky,
and I'm going to quote from
this week's Chronicle of Higher
Ed, that had a story on Charles
Murray and his new book.
And I'm going to read
through the opening
paragraph and the closing
paragraph to this piece.
It's an interesting piece,
you can read the whole thing.
But I think it sets the
context for today very well.
"Publishers, forget
about carefully reasoned,
nuanced discussions of
the issues of the day.
That stuff is for college
professors or yuppies
yammering away in their salons.
If you print politically
oriented books
and you want to
make the big bucks,
you need to think
like a boxing promoter
and stage fights that
will get attention.
And nothing, but
nothing draws hype
like a match up between
liberal pundits and the man
they love to hate,
the belligerent
behind the bell
curve, the warrior
against welfare, the proudly
political, incorrect Charles
Murray."
And it goes on to talk about
his most recent book, which
I will not go into, and
the arguments for and con.
But at the end of
the article, it's
summarized by saying,
"At the end of the day,
the cultural and economic divide
most illuminated by Coming
Apart--" that's
Murray's new book,
"might be one found in
scholarly publishing.
On one side are
authors and publishers
who produce nuanced books that
offer only conclusion stemming
from research and tend to be too
esoteric for wide readership.
On the other side are
authors and publishers
who cash in by
producing best selling
polemics in which research
is used to buttress
foregone conclusions."
So I think the
challenge for everybody
here is how to figure out
how to walk between Scylla
and Charybdis and come up
with something that you
can feel good about,
but, that also
satisfies the broader goals.
I'm going to yield the podium
to my colleague, Amy Brand,
Assistant Provost for
Faculty Appointments who
helped organize this
particular panel,
in fact all our book
publishing panels,
and the one thing you
need to know about Amy
is she was an editor at MIT
Press for many, many years,
and so has a lot of experience
with the book publishing world
so, Amy.
AMY BRAND: As Judy
mentioned, we've
been doing a whole
series of events
on book publishing I count seven
or eight in the last two years.
And the reason that we decided
to focus on trade books
is that in all of
these events questions
about how to write for a
broader audience keep coming up.
So surely questions
about working
with agents and
editors, and we'll
address those,
but also questions
about defining the crucial
difference in the writing style
that's required to reach
a broader audience.
In other words, how to unlearn
how to write like an academic.
So the great panel that we
have for you today is here,
not just to expound,
they're also here
to answer your questions
and engage in discussion,
and I trust you'll do your
part when the time comes.
We'll start with Angela von
der Lippe, Vice President
and Senior Editor at Norton.
Angela's also a
novelist, and among
her many other qualifications
for kicking off this panel,
Angela was an editor
at Harvard University
Press for many years, and has
also worked with many Harvard
faculty as authors.
We'll then turn to
Betsy Lerner who's
a literary agent in New York.
Betsy's author of the book
on writing that you now
all have, if you picked it
up at the registration table,
The Forest for the Trees.
Betsy also has a
blog on publishing,
which in her own words
in part, "strives
to address complex
issues involving
writers personalities,
especially,
but not limited to their
self-destructive proclivities.
But mostly, it's a
place to regularly vent
about publishing."
And then we'll turn to our
two eminent faculty members
and writers from the faculty
of Arts and Sciences,
Dan Gilbert Professor
of Psychology
and author of the New York
Times best seller, Stumbling
On Happiness, and Luke Menand,
Robert M Bass, Professor
of English, a regular
contributor to the New Yorker
and author most recently of
The Marketplace of Ideas.